à l'article 1er je suis saisi d'une
demande de parole de madame benbassa
merci madame la présidente l'article
l311 tiré 2 du nouveau code de la
justice pénale des mineurs prévoit
l'accompagnement des mineurs aux
auditions interrogatoire ces derniers
doivent toujours être accompagnés par un
adulte au cours d'une procédure afin de
leur permettre de recevoir toutes les
informations nécessaires sur les
décisions les concernant
lorsque le mineur ne peut être
accompagné par ses représentants légaux
ce qui est en grande majorité le cas
pour les mineurs isolés étrangers
le procureur de la république ou le juge
des enfants devrait désigner un adulte
appropriées afin d'assister l'enfant
dans ses nombreuses auditions
je souhaiterais mes chers collègues le
tenir votre attention sur les
difficultés que rencontrent les
magistrats pour désigner cet adulte
approprié ni les administrateurs haddock
ni les éducateurs la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse ni les avocats
n'accepte de tenir ce rôle qui ne leur
paraît pas compatible avec leurs
fonctions les mineurs se trouvent ainsi
privés du droit d'être accompagné et
rassuré par un adulte
lors des audiences aujourd'hui
stigmatiser les mineurs isolés ont suivi
pendant leur parcours migratoire de
nombreux traumatismes et sont très
souvent les victimes de réseaux et du
trafic d'êtres humains
il devrait à ce titre est davantage
protégés une clarification sur la
qualité de l'adulte à en proprié nous
sommes donc nécessaire dans le nouveau
code afin de préserver l'accès aux
droits de ces mines 1
c'est une demande qui va également dans
le sens du députéjean terlier chargée du
rapport à l'assemblée nationale sur la
ratification de l'ordonnancé sur la
justice des mineurs chevaux le mercy
mercy un amendement numéro 3 de madame
plus kerman
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux
cet amendement vise à supprimer cet
article tout d'abord parce que vous le
savez nous ne sommes pas favorables au
travail par ordonnance est encore plus
bien évidemment sur un projet un projet
tel que celui ci avec l'ampleur qui est
le sien cela prive de fait le parlement
d'un véritable débat sur un pan
essentiel de notre droit celui qui sera
applicable demain pour les mineurs de
notre pays et toute la difficulté
d'ailleurs qu'il y a eu à l'assemblée
nationale et que nous avons ici à sortir
finalement les parties de l'ordonance
pour pouvoir les amender sans avoir un
véritable débat sur le fond j'aurais
envie de bien nous sommes pas les seuls
à en être privé mais je les dis dans mon
intervention général finalement ce sont
l'ensemble des professionnels de la
justice des mineurs qui eux aussi sont
privés d'un véritable débat d'ailleurs
il le rappelait dans une tribune au
monde en décembre dernier selon eux
l'enjeu n'était pas de modifier la loi
mais plutôt de la faire appliquer et
effectivement ce recours par ordonnance
ton en tout cas à faire rapidement en se
privant peut-être un débat et j'entends
les arguments que vous nous avez déjà
donné
lorsque nous avons auditionné tout à
l'heure dans votre intervention en
général monsieur le garde des sceaux
cela fait maintenant certes plusieurs
années que ce texte est en débat mais
entre avoir un texte en débat que tout
le monde annonce est un texte qui crée
réellement la concertation pour engager
véritablement la réforme de cette
ordonnance de 1942 1945 qui certes avait
besoin d'être retravaillées
il y avait effectivement un large fossé
et c'est celui ci que nous dénonçons ce
soir quel est l'avis de la commission
alors oui madame kuperman comme vous
nous regrettons que
plongez sérail que sur un code de
justice pénale des mineurs et non pas un
code de l'enfance je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure
oui comme vous nous regrettons que ce
soit une loi de ratification qui nous
soit soumise ce soir parce que c'est
aussi un peu de court circuiter le
travail parlementaire mais la loi de
ratification est là donc maintenant on
aurait pu avoir une position
jusqu'au-boutiste en disant que nous
nous opposons à cette ratification mais
au fond nous pensons vraiment engley
revendique ses textes est un bon texte
que ce texte apporte des avancées qui
vont nous permettre de répondre plus
rapidement à cette vraie problématique
de la justice pénale des mineurs à ces
mineurs délinquants qui aujourd'hui
faute de réponse est bien s'enchaînent
dans des spirales de la délinquance
faute de réponse rapides donc nous
pensons que c'est un bon texte et nous
pensons aussi que ça devenir un très bon
texte
grâce aux améliorations du débat
parlementaire d'où notre position est
d'un avis défavorable à vis du
gouvernement
la présidente je préside la commission
des lois même le rapporteur la sénatrice
je suis longuement expliqué déjà et sans
surprise le gouvernement est défavorable
à l'amendement que vous présentez je
mets donc on voit l'amendement numéro 3
qui a reçu un double vie des faveurs au
pardon madame aribert une explication de
vote
nous n'allons pas voter cet amendement
parce que nous pensons qu'il faut le
débat
ce qui veut pas dire pour nous que ce
soit un bon texte ou un très bon texte
au contraire mais nous pensons que le
débat peut apporter un certain nombre de
clarifications voilà ce que je voulais
préciser merci je vais non
pardon je vais donc maintenant mettre
aux voix cet amendement numéro 3 qui a
reçu un double avis défavorable qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adoptée je mets aux voix l'article 1er
qui est pour et qui est contre
il est adopté après l'article 1er un
amendement de madame kuperman merci
madame la présidente sur garde des
sceaux au delà de la symbolique à
travers ce effectivement cet article
additionnel après l'article 1er nous
voulons finalement y compris suite à
votre réponse monsieur le garde des
sceaux à l'assemblée nationale choisir
le bon terme
le mieux adapté et oui nous préférons
celui d'enfants pour notre part à celui
deux mineurs la question n'est pas
forcément de tout réécrire mais
peut-être de données en tout cas la
définition pour rappeler qu'une personne
de moins de 18 ans est un enfant à part
entière nous continuons donc de penser
que le choix des mots est important et
de rappeler que un mineur n'est pas une
sorte de mini majeur mais d'abord un
enfant qu'elles sont attachés des droits
particuliers et qui doit donc faire
l'objet d'une protection particulière
d'ailleurs c'est le sens de nombreux
textes fondateurs qui consacre les
droits de l'enfant tout en font en
conflit avec la loi est un enfant en
danger la justice pénale des mineurs ne
devrait être considérée que comme une
modalité de la protection de l'enfance
c'est ainsi le sens de cet amour
quel est l'avis de la commission madame
la présidente monsieur garde des sceaux
madame la sénatrice qui kerman victimes
on adhère à l'idée que c'est une justice
humaine donc qui doit que doit être la
justice pénale des mineurs
néanmoins la notion de minorité de
majorité à l'âge de 18 ans elle est
clairement définie dans le code civil
l'article 388 et on pense que rajouter
une définition différente viendrait
complexifier serait redondante donc avis
défavorable ou sur le demande de retrait
un vis du gouvernement
exactement le même madame la présidente
nous écrivons la loi mineurs nous savons
ce que c'est enfin un adolescent il n'y
a pas de définition précise en tous les
cas pas de définition juridique de cela
donc vous préférez enfants adolescents
nous nous préférons mineurs c'est plus
clair défavorable jamais aux voix cet
amendement numéro 4 rectifié qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adoptée à l'article 1er bis à deux
amendements identiques faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune la moment de
l'euro 5 de même qu thurman oui je ne
vais pas allongé les débats ici tout
d'abord parce que j'en ai parlé déjà
bien évidemment dans l'intervention
général je crois que nous avons eu un
débat la question n'est pas faire de la
surenchère mais vraiment souligner et
monsieur le garde des sceaux
ce ne sont pas simplement les
parlementaires qui vous le disent et
vous le savez mieux que nous c'est
l'ensemble d'un système judiciaire qui
dit qu'aujourd'hui il est dans
l'incapacité concrètement de cette mise
en oeuvre au 31 mars
madame la rapporteur a proposé un report
de six mois est inévitablement en
période de repli
nous nous en contenterons cependant nous
pensons que à une année ne serait pas de
trop ne serait ce que pour éviter parce
que nous sommes dans une situation
particulière la superposition
d'instruction version ordonnance de 45
et version texte que nous sommes en
train de débattre
rappelons tout de même que l'année 2020
à vue
un engorgement de nombreuses
juridictions temps par un début de
l'année ralenti notamment par une
mobilisation dénonçant la réforme des
retraites d'un certain nombre non
négligeable d'avocats puis bien
évidemment par le confinement et les
conséquences de la crise sanitaire que
nous vivons et donc nous pensons que un
an permettrait à minima justement ce
premier des des engorgements pardon et
ensuite un retour un peu plus à la
normale même si bien évidemment monsieur
le garde des sceaux dans toute réforme
il y à une date et qu'il y a un temps de
chevauchement entre un ancien système un
nouveau système
en tout cas pour une meilleure clarté de
la justice des mineurs qui sera rendu
demain
nous pensons qu'il nous faut un délai
supplémentaire le 49 mais monsieur soeur
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des sceaux
chers collègues c'est parce que nous
voulons que la réforme réussie ce même
si nous avons des critiques parfois
l'aude sur le texte qui est présente et
que nous demandons comme l'a fait madame
pitt y herman que le l'implication du
texte soit reportée d'un an
madame maryse carrère que nous avons
entendu écouté avec attention tout à
l'heure écrivait dans son rapport au nom
de la commission des lois sur la loi de
finances pour 2021 au titre de la pjj
la commission des lois je cite a
constaté lors de l'examen de ce projet
de loi que tant les juridictions pour
mineurs que les services de protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse ne serait pas
prêt à mettre en oeuvre la réforme à la
date prévue
les développements informatiques ont
également pris du retard de même que le
travail de formation des prix des
personnels qui doit près
c'est dès l'application de la réforme le
risque d'une mise en oeuvre plus
formelle que pratique de la réforme et
d'importantes ans de transition cours de
l'année 2000 21 paraît donc réel je cite
simplement ce que disait notre collègue
et qui a été adopté par tous de la
commission j'ajoute que monsieur le
garde des sceaux nous avons reçu les
représentants des magistrats
les représentants des avocats les
représentant des éducateurs spécialisés
les représentants des spip et de la pjj
et ils nous disent tous qu'il faut du
temps pour la mise en oeuvre de cette
réforme
alors nous savons ce qui s'est passé le
recours à l'ordonnancé bien sûr la
procédure accélérée
puisque vous savez monsieur le garde des
sceaux que plus aucun texte sans famille
à part le texte sur la bioéthique n'a
droit à la procédure normale qui devrait
pourtant être en vigueur pour un texte
comme celui là nous avons vu la
précipitation avec laquelle les textes
d'application sont parus avant même que
le texte ne soit voté
si nous défendons cet amendement c'est
pas du tout contre la réforme
c'est pour madame rossignol je pense que
vous l'aurez compris une réforme qui
soit efficace
quel est l'avis de la commission madame
est présente mais c'est le garde des
sceaux mes chers collègues nous avons
émis déjà nos réserves sur l'entrée en
vigueur au 31 mars la commission des
lois a adopté un report de six mois qui
nous paraît justifiée et nécessaire
en l'espèce données en une année
supplémentaire ne servirait pas la
réforme mais au contraire des
mobiliserait
les acteurs et c'est pas le but
recherché donc nous donnant un avis
défavorable
pas de ces abandons quel est l'avis du
gouvernement madame la présidente
monsieur le président la commission des
lois même reporter madame la sénatrice
qui kerman vous essayez la suppression
il n'y parvenant pas vous essayez le
dilatoire
pardon je vais vous répondre sur cette
question j'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure
dans mon discours que je n'étais pas
insensible aux délais qui étaient
envisagés par la commission des lois
mais à la vérité je dois le dire pour
des raisons différentes je m'expliquais
une fois pour toutes sur ces questions
ce sénateur ça me permettra également de
vous répondre
on pensait quand même bien que nous
n'avons pas préparé cette réforme dans
le but qu'elles ne fonctionnent pas
parce que quand même accordé
accordez-nous cela aux mains ou aux noms
ono nom d'un minimum de cohérence
je veux également dire ici que ce n'est
pas la dnacg qui porte ce texte mais la
dpjj quand même des professionnels de la
justice pour mineurs impliqués il le
démontre tous les jours et qu'il me soit
permis ici de la rendre hommage nous
avons fait expertiser par les services
d'inspection générale de la justice à ma
demande quel était le niveau de
préparation des juridictions pour
recevoir cette réforme dont on peut
s'accorder à dire qu'elle est une bonne
réforme les services nous ont dit il ya
dix juridictions qui sont en fragilité
et nous avons traité ses fragilités dans
les dix juridictions concernées ne pas
vous redire ici ce que nous avons
apportées en moyens humains pour régler
ces questions mais nous l'avons fait et
donc nous avions
j'avais la certitude que cette réforme
pouvait entrer en application à la date
que nous avions envisagé
seulement voilà la réalité c'est que le
texte à bouger avec l'intervention du
jld vous le savez j'ai consenti à cela
pour des raisons qui tiennent à
l'impartialité c'est une discussion que
nous avons eue
j'y reviendrai dans non venue ici devant
la haute assemblée
et nous nous sommes rendu compte à la
date du 15 janvier et pas avant qu'il y
aurait une difficulté dans les
applicatifs
à raison de ces j'ose dire
pardonnez moi l'intrusion du jld dans
cette procédure
effectivement j'ai eu l'honneur de dire
déjà à madame le rapporteur que nous
concédions sur le report de la nappe
non pas en raison du fait que vous vous
dites mais les juridictions n'étaient
pas prêtes j'entends cela c'est le
sénateur sur 10 les représentants des
magistrats
il ya un certain nombre de magistrats
qui m'ont dit qu'ils étaient
parfaitement prêt et je le redis la
direction de la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse dit la même chose
et pardonnez moi j'ai tendance à croire
mes services mais en sur cette
difficulté inhérente à la production du
jld dans la procédure
nous nous sommes retrouvés confrontés à
une réalité et donc j'ai dit et j'ai
redit tout à l'heure dans mon discours
que nous étions d'accord pour un report
mais pardon un report qui ne nous amène
pas aux calendes grecques il faut que
sceptre et formes prennent corps et
qu'elle soit applicable et nous sommes
en train de régler cette question du jld
et la date qui a été proposée est une
date que je retiens comme tout à fait
réaliste voilà pour quelle raison je
suis évidemment défavorable totalement
défavorable aux deux amendements qui ont
été présents même plus qu'ammann merci
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux nous allons passer au minimum
deux soirées pour débattre de ce projet
de loi
effectivement peut-être avec une
méconnaissance de la déroute donc je
préfère tout de suite vous prévenir mais
je ne suis pas un marchand de tapis je
suis sénatrice et donc je ne fais pas
repasse
et dans un autre article un amendement
parce que je n'aurais pas eu
satisfaction précédent et donc j'ai une
conscience et j'ai un engagement
politique parce que c'est cela la
démocratie
et donc oui mais je les dis notre route
pas plus sur votre texte que sur un
autre
nous sommes opposés à ce recours de plus
en plus systématique non pas simplement
par votre gouvernement mais par les
gouvernements qui se succèdent des
ordonnances doux l'amendement de
suppression de l'article 1er en revanche
sur cet amendement là nous proposons un
report non pas parce que nous n'avons
pas eu satisfaction précédemment mais
parce que vous savez finalement être élu
c'est représenter et donc quand on quand
un projet de loi comme celui ci arrive
avec l'ambition qui est donnée bien les
uns les autres nous auditionnons nous
rencontrons nous échangeons nous
téléphonons recevons des courriers et
bien évidemment selon y compris les
projets de société que nous défendrons
ils ne sont pas les mêmes parce que
c'est un sirh en démocratie est bien
bien évidemment nous nous appuyons sur
telle ou telle organisation collectif
d'associations groupement professionnel
organisations syndicales etc etc et nous
nous appuyons pas toutes et tous
d'ailleurs sur les mêmes et donc vous
savez tout aussi bien que moi même mieux
que moi qu'il ya aujourd'hui un débat
dans un certain nombre de procès un
certain nombre de professionnels de la
justice
quant à la faisabilité d'une application
et nous savons également par ailleurs
parce que en tant que parlementaire nous
ne découvrons pas ce matin la
problématique de la justice qu'il y a
des retard qu'il ya des retards sur
informatique il y as je le disais des
engorgements et je ne jette la pierre à
personne
l'année 2020 a été ce qu'elle était mais
parce qu'il ya eu aussi pendant des
années des retards en termes de
personnel en termes de moyens qui
viennent aujourd'hui bien évidemment
alourdir et donner plus de temps que
nécessaire à ces procédures
donc oui je le redis nous déposons cet
amendement pas parce que nous n'avons
pas eu satisfaction aux précédents tout
comme nous
encore une vingtaine d'amendements mais
même si vous nous dites non sur celui ci
nous en déposeront donc pour continuer
le débat dans la langueur madrid
je mets aux voix ces deux amendements le
5 et le 49 qui est pour et qui est
contre
ils ne sont pas adoptées je mets donc on
voit l'article 1er bis à nouveau qui est
pour et qui est contre
il est adopté je me vois l'article 1er
bis qui est pour et qui est contre
il est adopté 5 amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune à
l'article 1er terre à le 62e madame
benbassa merci madame la présidente le
présent commandement a pour objet
d'instaurer une présomption irréfragable
d'irresponsabilité pénale pour les
mineurs de moins de 14 ans en effet dans
sa rédaction actuelle le code de justice
pénale des mineurs pose le principe
d'une présomption simple donnons
discernement des enfants de moins de 13
ans que le magistrat pourra facilement
écarté or avec une telle rédaction la
france demain en contradiction avec la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant qui le commandent aux états de
fixer un seuil d'accessibilité à la
sanction pénale claire il convient de
tenir compte donc de la maturité
émotionnelle mental intellectuel de
l'enfant dont la personnalité est en
construction
nous proposons ainsi par cet amendement
de retenir le seuil de 14 ans déjà
appliquée dans plusieurs pays européens
à l'instar de l'espagne de l'allemagne
et de l'italie
le merci à ma demande numéro 6 madame
plus clairement oui merci à madame la
présidente monsieur garde des sceaux
dans le même sens nous proposons de
remplacer la propos la présomption
simple selon laquelle l'enfant de moins
de 13 ans ne disposerait pas du
discernement suffisant pour voir sa
responsabilité pénale engagée par une
présomption irréfragable
en cela il répond à une exigence
essentielle à nos yeux le droit pénal
des mineurs doit respecter le principe
selon lequel chacun a le droit de
bénéficier d'un procès équitable pour
cela l'enfant doit avoir pleinement la
capacité de participer à son procès
cette compréhension constitue un aspect
fondamental du discernement de son
appréciation
cela d'ailleurs été rappelé en 2018 par
le temps de ce ne ne bouge pas cela a
été rappelé en 2018 par jacques toubon
jeunes en abuseraient pas à madame la
présidente rassurez-vous jarre fait cela
a été rappelé en 2018 par jacques toubon
alors défenseur des droits qui
expliquait que je cite pour que l'enfant
bénéficie d'un procès équitable
il doit avoir pleinement la capacité de
participer à son procès il doit
comprendre pourquoi il est là les
sanctions pénales susceptible d'être
prononcée contre lui mais aussi les
mécanismes des recours judiciaires
or en dessous d'un certain âge un enfant
s'il peut avoir compris même voulu son
acte a en revanche difficilement une
telle compréhension de la procédure
pénale dans laquelle ils se trouvent
impliqués
de plus l'actuel défenseur des droits
claire hédon soulignent que la
responsabilité pénale continuer à
reposer sur la notion de discernement
sans pour autant que autant que cette
notion soit défini ce qui implique des
enfants de moins de 13 ans pourront
toujours faire l'objet d'une procédure
pénale
il n'y aura donc pas de réel changement
par rapport au régime applicable
aujourd'hui des enfants de 7 8 ans
pourront toujours faire l'objet de
poursuites pénales comme cela peut
arriver actuellement pire comme cela est
rappelé par de nombreux acteurs
cette notion de discernement laisse
place à une grande diversité de
pratiques suivant les
héron le principe d'égalité devant la
loi et la justice bien que madame la
rapporteure et tenter de définir en
commission cette notion de discernement
elle demeure encore à nos yeux assez
floue alors que son appréhension est
centrale pour définir la culpabilité
d'un mineur les voies de recours contre
une telle appréciation ne sont pas
précisés tel est le sens de l'amendement
l'amendement 50 monsieur soeur merci
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues
l'amendement que je présente va
strictement dans le même sens que les
précédents la convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant demande à chaque
état par ci de fixer un âge minimum en
dessous duquel un mineur ne peut être
poursuivi pénalement
ainsi la rédaction actuelle de l'article
l
11-1 de l'ordonance du 11 septembre 2019
ne permet pas de répondre à cette
exigence dans la mesure où en dessous de
13 ans il y à une présomption
d'irresponsabilité pénale qui est simple
et qui n'est pas irréfragable le comité
des droits de l'enfant de genève a été
très clair à ce sujet il s'est exprimé à
de nombreuses reprises et il précise
qu'il ne peut y avoir de poursuites
pénales mais seulement des mesures
éducatives
à cet égard et les méduses les mesures
éducatives d'ailleurs tout le monde en
conviendra ne sont pas ne sont pas
purement cosmétique elles sont très
réels très forte et l'objectif du texte
est de leur donner la prime le primat
par ailleurs prévoir une responsabilité
pénale pour les mineurs de moins de 13
ans ne signifie donc pas une absence de
réponse
et enfin pour ce qui est des jeunes de
plus de 13 ans la responsabilité pénale
doit être présumé est liée à la capacité
de discernement qu'il appartient aux
magistrats de déterminer donc je crois
que les choses sont très claires
quand un autre point de désaccord sur ce
sujet précis
madame boyer pour le 51 cet amendement
vise à répondre en partie aux
difficultés auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés en particulier celle des
mineurs ultra violent et celle de ce que
le ministre appelle l'ensauvagement de
la société terme qui a peut-être été
contestés lorsqu'il a été prononcé la
première fois mais qui malheureusement
du fait de l'actualité et partager
aujourd'hui par tous je voudrais
simplement rappeler une affaire assez
sordide et a particulièrement triste que
les mineurs qui ont frappé marin vous
savez ce jeune homme courageux qui était
venu au secours d'un couple qui
s'embrassaient et qui a été tabassé
jusqu'à en être handicapé à vie avait
interpellé 18 fois je crois monsieur le
ministre si ma mémoire est bonne donc
cet amendement propose d'instaurer un
âge minimum de responsabilité pénale des
mineurs à partir de 16 ans tout en
conservant d'exigence morale du
discernement en deux ça vous le savez
l'article du code de la justice pénale
des mineurs celui qui est relatif à la
responsabilité pénale des mineurs
prévoit une présomption de
responsabilité pénale à partir de 13 ans
une présomption d'irresponsabilité en
deçà afin de rapprocher le droit
français des règles du droit
international et de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
qui exige un âge minimum en dessous
duquel les enfants sont présumé n'avoir
pas la capacité d'enfreindre la loi
pénale c'est la raison pour laquelle
dans le respect de ses fondamentaux
je vous propose deux complets
et ce dispositif en rendant responsable
des mineures de 16 et 18 ans tout en
maintenant une présomption de
responsabilité pour des mineurs de 13 à
16 ans l'amendement suivant est un
amendement de repli identique que je me
permets madame la présidente de défendre
en même temps je remercie ces faits quel
est l'avis de la commission sur un ses
amendements
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
alors c'est vrai que c'est un amendement
conjoint pose plusieurs questions la
première c'est celle de l'âge pivot est
l'occasion de le dire dans la discussion
générale
c'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas de consensus
aujourd'hui sur l'âge de 13 ans de 14
ans si on regarde l'ensemble des pays de
l'union européenne certains choisi vie
tant certains certains sont même allés
jusqu'à 18 ans et on voit même que au
sein de tout ce que nous avons
auditionné là aussi l'âge peut varier
nous considérons que dans le droit
positif français l'âge de 13 ans est
reconnu et que ça paraît être un bon
maillage de développement correspondant
à l'étape développement des des enfants
donc nous sommes favorables plus tôt à
l'âge de 13 ans que celui de 14 ans sur
la présomption irréfragable ou
l'irresponsabilité pénale tous imposés
présomption irréfragable de nom
discernement c'est le même effet nous
considérons que le dispositif de la
présomption simple tel qu'il est adoptée
aujourd'hui dans le texte permet de
faire confiance aux juges il nous paraît
important dans le cas de la justice
pénale des mineurs que les juges des
enfants qui sont des juges spécialisés
qui connaissent bien
c'est un principe de base le
développement des enfants puissent
adapter la réponse en fonction du
développement de l'enfant et la
présomption simple de denon discernement
avant 13 ans de discernement après 13
ans permet de faire glisser
la réponse pénale en fonction des
situations parle de certaines situations
c'est vrai qu'il ne faut pas légiférer
par rapport à des situations précises et
le droit ne doit pas répondre à telle ou
telle situation néanmoins elles peuvent
permettre d'expliquer et d'éclairer et
si on prend la sphère de la jeune eva l
on voit bien que les auteurs avaient
moins de 13 ans et que c'est la question
du discernement se pose très clairement
pour eux donc sur l'amendement 60 de
rectifier ce sera un avis défavorable
sur l'amendement 6 pour les mêmes
raisons pareil
idem sur l'amendement 50 rectifier ce
qui concerne cette fois ci des
responsabilités pénales et des effets
sont les mêmes que la présomption
irréfragable de nom discernement sur
l'amendement de madame boyer le 51
rectifié je pas sûr que de créer trois
seuils viendrait simplifiée permettre
une réponse véritable notamment pour une
responsabilité pleine et entière des 16
à 18 ans même si c'est consiste en un
groupe important de jeunes mineurs
délinquants et souvent aussi enfermé
dans cette spirale néanmoins aujourd'hui
le juge peut renverser l'excusé de
minorité et là aussi je pense qu'il faut
faire confiance aux juges c'est pas la
peine de complexifier en créant des
strates supplémentaire donc j'y mettrai
aussi un avis défavorable et sur
l'amendement de repli même chose quel
est l'avis du gouvernement sur ces cinq
amendements c'est le même avis madame la
présidente
d'abord on va rappeler que le mineur de
13 ans ne peut pas faire l'objet d'une
mesure coercitive
il faut le rappeler et qui ait pas de
confusion sur ce point ensuite nous
partons du principe qu'il faut faire
confiance aux juges des enfants
qui a des gamins de 12 ans qui ont
davantage de discernement que certains
gamins de 14
nous souhaitons également bien sûr qu'il
y est une réponse judiciaire adaptée à
l'âge évidemment mais également au
discernement
je pense avoir à peu près tout dit je me
joins aux explications de madame le
rapporteur et j'ajoute que dans quelques
instants le gouvernement proposera un
amendement pour définir ce qu'est le
discernement
je devrais lire le mieux définir pour
faire un certain nombre d'assurances
encore parce que évidemment la loi
pénale doit être strictement encadré et
nous nous servirons vous le verrez dans
la définition qui nous est proposée par
la cour de cassation mais pas de
d'explications de vote je vais donc
mettre aux voix
ces cinq amendements qui ont tous reçu
un double avis défavorable la commission
du gouvernement
le soixante deux pieds pour qui et
contre il n'est pas adopté le 6 qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adoptée même vote sur le 50
le 51 kg et pour madame voyez c'est
votre amendement vous votez pas adacore
donc vous le retirez d'accord est le
suivant aussi j'imagine donc jeu mais on
voit maintenant quatre amendements je
mens discusions 4 amendement faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
27 de monsieur soeur c'est madame arrimé
au pardon madame arrêt bec c'est pas
grave c'était c'était assez logique
puisque je sais que nous sommes donc
fois sur deux je me trompe pas non non
non non mais c'était c'était indiqué
monsieur sueur dont vous aviez tout à
fait raison simplement lassé sur la
définition comme je le disais dans mon
propos de 10 de la discussion générale
par rapport à la définition du
discernement
nous voudrions le
donner une définition en expliquant que
le mineur est capable de discernement
lorsqu'ils ont voulu et compris l'acte
et là on reprend la jurisprudence de
l'arrêt laboute de la cour de cassation
de 1956 et qui a été réitérée et l'idée
c'est vraiment de la notion de d'avoir
compris et d'avoir voulu
et on irait même au delà c'est à dire
qu'il faut être aussi en mesure de
comprendre la procédure applicable et
ses enjeux merci le 71
mais c'est solide merci madame la
présidente
la rapporteur a utilement introduit au
sein du code de justice pénale des
mineurs
une définition du discernement
cette définition relève en effet
actuellement d'une jurisprudence
constante depuis 1956 qui vise non
seulement à la compréhension call mineur
de son acte mais également sa volonté de
le commettre
afin de ne pas affaiblir la portée de
cette jurisprudence dans la définition
qui sera inscrit dans la loi désormais
le présent amendement vise à y intégrer
une référence expresse à la volonté du
mineur et à sa compréhension de la
procédure pénale
voilà l'objet de cet amendement tout à
l'heure je présenterai enfin il ya un
amendement de repli le 110 donc
considérer que j'ai d'ores et déjà
descendre juge madame la présidente
oui d'autant qu'il ya un amendement du
gouvernement identique de 75 sur le
ministre oui madame la présidente que
comme votre collègue et hani mohammed le
gouvernement dépose et comme je
l'évoquais dans mon discours tout à
l'heure un amendement de précisions sur
la notion de discernement nous avons
choisi de recopier servilement les
interruptions tue-t-il la définition qui
a été donné par la cour de cassation
belles références il en est vous me
l'accorderez dans un vieillard et qui
est un arrêt du 11 décembre 56 qui a
fait contre consensus depuis lors
discernement il faut que les gamins y
compris voulu son acte qu'il soit apte à
comprendre le sens de la procédure
pénale dont il fait l'objet
ce volet là est extrêmement important
parce que il faut évidemment
la réponse pédagogique qui sera apporté
par la justice puisse être compris sinon
ça n'a strictement aucun sens et la
justice tourne à vide pour elle même ce
qui n'est quand même pas le but
donc voilà la définition que nous
proposons du discernement sait plus
comment dire est plus précis que la
notion de maturité par exemple un mot
qu'on a beaucoup utilisé ici quelques
quelques jours de cela et sur lequel
nous avons déjà disserter et voilà le
gouvernement le gouvernement se réfère à
cette définition qui est unie finition
qui fait aujourd'hui référence quand il
est question de définir le discernement
madame la rapporteure quel est l'avis de
la commission sur ce les amendements oui
madame la présidente monsieur garde des
sceaux men et chers collègues vous avez
compris nous sommes tous attentifs à ce
qu'il y ait dans ce code de justice
pénale des mineurs une définition de
cette notion du discernement qui est la
pierre angulaire de la responsabilité
pénale du mineur
cette définition nous l'avions proposé
autour d'un concept certes aujourd'hui
peu juridique qu'on en a bien conscience
celui de la maturité nous paraissait
important que les sanctions prononcées à
l'égard des auteurs délinquants des
mineurs délinquants traîne véritablement
en compte l'état d'évolution et l'état
compréhension effectivement des mineurs
et notamment de leur aptitude à
comprendre c'est la raison pour laquelle
et vous l'avez dit monsieur garde des
sceaux c'est clair qu'il ya une base qui
est de cette jurisprudence constante de
l'arrêt de principe la boudent que tout
le monde a cité et qu'il est nécessaire
et utile de se référer bien évidemment à
cette constance jurisprudentielle mais
nous sommes aussi
très attentif et très ouvert c'est
l'intérêt des débats parlementaires et
de l'enrichissement mutuel à la joue
concernant l'aptitude à comprendre le
sens de la procédure nous paraît
important c'est que le jeune puisse
inscrire et puissent aussi comprendre
les enjeux
même si nous pensons que c'est pas
forcément tant la procédure qui doit
comprendre que la sanction qu'il va être
prononcée à son encontre un a peur
jusque là notion de procédure soit un
peu plus abscons que celle de deux
sanctions qui parlera peut-être plus aux
jeunes c'est pour ça que nous mettons un
avis favorable avant d'amendements donc
c'est un avis défavorable sur
l'amendement 27 parce qu'il manque cette
précision de l'aptitude à contrairement
à comprendre et nous mettons un un avis
favorable à l'amendement de monsieur
swahili et du gouvernement puisqu'ils
sont identiques et donc un avis
défavorable à mondrepuis kynapse
monsieur le garde des sceaux quel est
votre avis sur le 27 parce que j'imagine
que vous venez favorable sur les 71
exactement madame la présidente vous
avez bien imaginez donc le 27
défavorable voilà je vais donc mettre
aux voix madame marie baie je veux bien
que consommer n'est qu'on consomme usées
à dire bon je suis favorable cela n'est
pas celui-là je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire madame le rapporteur que le nôtre
est incomplet parce qu'il n'a pas la
notion de comprendre alors comprennent
qu'on précise bien que le 10ème rang il
ya discernement lorsqu'on a voulu et
compris l'acte donc soit vous vous êtes
mal exprimée sans qu'il soit incomplet
et que l'on veut bien admettre que
l'amendement de 71 rectifié 75 sont un
peu plus complet et donc aller dans ce
sens là mais nous dit pas que le nôtre
et ne parle pas de comprendre
merci madame la rapporteure oui
précision je me suis alors peut-être mal
exprimé où vous m'avez mal compris the
c'est l'aptitude à comprendre le sens de
la procédure c'est pour ça que on pense
que l'amendement
notre collègue thani mohamed soilihi et
qui est identique et donc l'argument du
gouvernement puisque ce sont les mêmes
sont plus comment dire
complet exactement et intègre cette
notion d' à petit et à comprendre la
procédure c'est à dire que le jeune
n'est pas simplement ne doit pas
simplement comprendre ce qu'il a fait
mais il doit comprendre aussi ce qu'ils
encourent et ce qui se passe et cela
nous paraît important aussi que ces
éléments soient pris en compte et sarah
se rapporte
cette notion de maturité c'est pour ça
qu'on préfère ces amendements là les
vôtres étant une bonne base puisqu'ils
reprennent toute façon la décision
jurisprudentielle de l'arel aboud dont
on a dit que c'est l'arrêt de principe
l'arrêt socle donc cette précision est
en fait en retire le nôtre au profit des
deux autres d'accord je vais donc mettre
aux voix
l'amendement 71 qui est pour et 75 en
même temps qui est pour et qui est
contre
ils sont adoptés le 70 tombe vers
retirer monsieur solide
je me vois l'article le premier ter à
nouveau qui est pour et qui est contre
il est adopté article additionnel après
l'article 6 l'amendement numéro 20
défendu par madame associés merci madame
la présidente
chaque collègue je continue aussi bien
où les textes internationaux que
nationaux présents de la détention d'un
mineur comme une normalité uniquement
acceptable en dernier recours et
pourtant le nombre de mineurs enfermés
augmente 75 à 80 % d'entre eux sont
encore présumé innocent les placer en
détention provisoire les causes de cette
augmentation du nombre de mineurs
détenus doivent être scrutées
sans omettre d'ajouter au nombre de
mines
détenue dans un établissement
pénitentiaire ou en centre de rétention
administrative
ceux qui sont enfermés on a eu
l'occasion d'en parler hier en centre
éducatif fermé
nous ne sommes pas en tant d'émoi bien
nous ne sommes bien évidemment pas pour
dissoudre toute haine à l'égard des
mineurs que ce loin que cela soit bien
entendu mais que dire de la peine
d'emprisonnement
déjà bien contesté dans le monde adulte
que dire de ce modèle qui nous semble
révolue qui se rapprochent davantage
excusez moi de l'expression mais j'en
trouve pas une autre des bagnes
d'enfants d'avant-guerre que des centres
éducatifs fermés
qu'on nous vante comme des modèles j'ai
dit excusez moi des propos que j'utilise
et vous savez vous saviez très bien le
faire en d'autres temps monsieur le
ministre
donc on nous vend comme des modèles en
matière de redressement de la
délinquance juvénile je sais bien que ça
vous plaît pas mais c'est ainsi il
apparaît selon nous urgent d'en limiter
la portée en autorisant la détention
provisoire des mineurs qu'à ceux âgés de
plus de saison à quoi ressemble un
individu de 13 ans et je ne fais pas
lien avec un autre texte dont nous avons
débattu il ya quelques jours ici au
sénat à quoi ressemble un individu de 13
ans de 14 ans un grand enfant un tout
jeune adolescent avec un degré de
maturité et de discernement encore bien
fragile dans la majorité des cas à tel
point que ce texte fixe un seuil
d'irresponsabilité pénale présumé pour
les mineurs de 13 ans mais en parallèle
ces mineurs de 13 ans et plus en coups
et plus encourt une peine pénale
d'enfermement cela est pour nous un non
sens auquel nous tentons de remédier je
dis bien que nous tentons de remédier
avec cet amendement
merci madame la rapporteure votre avis
s'il vous plaît oui merci à main
présente monsieur ministre alors le code
de la justice pénale des mineurs
autorise le placement en détention des
mineurs uniquement de plus de 13 ans
primo entre 13 et 16 ans elle n'est
possible détention provisoire qu'en
matière criminelle ou si le jeune s'est
volontairement soustrait à des
obligations dans le cadre de son
placement en centre éducatif fermé
donc je pense qu'il est difficile
vraiment de se passer de cette détention
provisoire pour des situations et on
vient d'en parler qui sont
particulièrement graves
deux jeunes qui sont restés rangs de
jeunes qui ne remplissent pas leurs
obligations et par moments la détention
provisoire est un mal nécessaire
favorable merci madame le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre votre avis je vais
redire madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
adam la rapporteure la présidente que je
n'ai pas changé et je vais pas vous le
chantez non je vais pas vous le chantez
mais je prie de le croire bon c'est
effectivement un mal nécessaire
on déplore tout ce qu'un gamin soit
envoyée en prison mais je voudrais que
vous entendiez loin des caricatures
peut-être parler de bagnes tout à
l'heure n'était ce pas un peu excessif
pourrait seulement vous dire que parfois
le juge a besoin de cela et qu'il faut
lui laisser des outils et qu'il apprécie
et que parfois des gagnants vous dise en
fin de parcours et j'en ai connu que le
premier séjour en prison si les cours
peut être salutaire
ce n'est pas quelque chose que j'invente
le moins possible mais parfois c'est
particulièrement utile
voilà pourquoi je suis défavorable à
l'amendement que vous déposez madame la
présidente
merci monsieur le ministre à je mets
donc aux voiles l'amendement numéro 20
avec deux avis défavorables qui votent
pour qu'ils votent contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté article additionnel
après l'article si sa maman 55 rectifié
bis madame boyer
merci madame la présidente madame la
rapporteure monsieur le ministre on l'a
dit à plusieurs reprises dans cet
hémicycle en parlant de la justice des
mineurs à mineur ne peut être
complètement ne peut-être pardon
complètement responsable de ses actes
lorsqu'il commet une infraction et nous
devons rappeler aux adultes leurs
responsabilités et du quatier le
ministre de l'intérieur l'a rappelé
abondamment ces jours ci en commentant
d'ailleurs cette sinistre affaire du
petit youri en disant que la
responsabilité des parents étaient
importantes puisque c'étaient des
mineurs souvent qu'ils étaient dans des
bandes et il a cité plusieurs chiffres
aussi monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je voulais vous rappeler que
le devoir d'éducation doit primer sur le
pouvoir de punir et vous l'avez rappelé
à cet instant or le devoir d'éducation
ne relève pas seulement de la justice et
de l'état
il relève d'abord et avant tout des
parents
l'objet de cet amendement est de
restaurer l'autorité des parents qui ont
le devoir d'exercer sur leurs enfants
parce qu'ils sont l'auteur et parce que
ils en sont les ascendants ils sont
aussi les premiers responsables exercer
l'autorité sur un enfant ce n'est pas
nécessairement le bris mais dans
l'exercice des libertés c'est lui donner
un cadre lui imposer des limites dans
lesquelles il pourra plus tard
s'épanouir d'ailleurs c'est ce que dit
maurice berger dont on a lu je suis sur
chacun d'entre nous ici sur ces bancs
plusieurs articles ces jours ci or dans
le contexte socio-économique souvent
difficiles beaucoup de parents ont fini
par baisser les bras dans l'éducation
qu'ils étaient censés donner à leurs
enfants
disqualifié socialement ils se sentent
plus un devoir d'intervenir dans la vie
sociale de leurs enfants
ce rappel à la responsabilité parentale
doit s'effectuer de façon ferme et
solennel il semble qu'aujourd'hui seuls
l'institution judiciaire soit en mesure
d'avoir un impact réel sur les parents
souvent démobilisés l'objectif premier
de ce texte n'est toutefois pas de punir
les parents mais de créer chez eux une
sorte d'électrochoc une prise de
conscience afin qu'ils seraient
investissent avec fermeté dans
l'éducation et la surveillance de leurs
enfants
les cause de l'aggravation de la
violence sont multiples chez les
mineures et tiennent en partie à
l'affaiblissement de l'autorité à
l'encadrement parental
les enfants concernés sont souvent
victimes d'une perte de repères et d'un
désengagement de leurs familles
aussi l'autorité parentale se définit
comme l'ensemble des droits des devoirs
ayant pour finalité l'intérêt de
l'enfant
pour conclure je voudrais vous dire que
sur le plan pénal selon lequel nul les
responsables pénalement que de son
propre fait empêche de donner toute
sanction directe des parents pour des
faits de leurs enfants
il ne s'agit pas ici de remettre en
cause ce principe en instaurant une
responsabilité pénale du fait d'autrui
mais de replacer l'autorité parentale au
coeur de l'éducation des enfants
ainsi il est proposé de diversifier les
possibilités d'action contre les parents
qui testerait qui resterait passive
pardon face à l'évolution défavorable
des mineurs et qui maximise par défaut
de surveillance les risques et la dérive
vers la délinquance le présent
amendement propose un contrat
d'engagement réciproque qu'ils soient
signés par les titulaires de vérité
largement dépassé votre temps service de
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
afin de garantir le respect de leurs
habitants nous donner votre avis je suis
désolé mais là c'est ici mais en seconde
déjà en plus merci madame à présente
monsieur le ministre
effectivement dans le code de justice
pénale des mineurs
on en n'est nécessairement besoin
d'interdire la place des parents la
responsabilisation des parents est
essentiel dans le cadre de
l'accompagnement des mineurs pour faire
en sorte que ces derniers s'implique
notamment dans les mesures éducatives
qui sont prononcés à l'égard des mineurs
certes dans un certain nombre de cas les
parents sont défaillants néanmoins danse
à 100 certain nombre de cas ces derniers
ne s'implique pas véritablement c'est le
sens de l'amendement qu'à déposer ma
collègue valérie boyer alors là c'est
sous la forme d'un contrat alors un
contrat c'est un accord c'est un
engagement c'est du dur de la
responsabilisation des parents auxquels
et est associée des sanctions alors je
sais pas si les sanctions seront adaptés
c'est une faculté en tout cas qui est
laissée aux juges et qui permettrait de
favoriser nous l'espérons cette
implication des parents donc nous sommes
plutôt favorable merci madame le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre votre
avis je suis totalement madame la
présidente
c'est le président de la commission des
lois madame la rapporteure la sénatrice
viscéralement absolument opposé à cet
amendement qui pour moi est d'une totale
injustice la précarisation de gens qui
déjà souvent sont fragiles sur le plan
économique parce que voyez-vous la
statistique démontre à l'évidence que la
délinquance c'est souvent d'abord la
sphère des pauvres gens pas que mais
souvent la statistique le du monde
mon expérience professionnelle mais pas
que il suffit d'aller regarder tous les
livres de sociologie qui traite de la
délinquance et je voudrais vous dire
quelque chose à l'assemblée nationale
pour répondre à la marine le pen qui est
sur la même position
je lui ai fait part d'un souvenir je
vous êtes très bas je vous rassure c'est
une femme qui élève trois enfants seuls
deux de ces enfants ne pose strictement
aucun problème
l'autre est délinquant j'ai dit dont
discours que on parlait des enfants et
que nous parlions de nos enfants et sept
femmes non ce que vous suggérez madame
se retrouveraient financièrement temps
de travail mais pour quel crime
je suis totalement opposé à ça sauf que
c'est totalement inhumain totalement
injuste mais chacun voit midi à sa porte
merci monsieur le ministre à je vais
donc mettre aux voix
c'est un moment 55 rectifié bis
explications
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre vous êtes bien
évidemment libre de votre position comme
moi je suis libre de défendre la mienne
mais ce que je voulais vous dire je suis
quand même assez perturbé par la façon
dont vous nous répondez sur le plan de
la morale comme s'il y avait d'un côté
les gentils et de l'autre les méchants
et comme si la proposition que je
formulais était une
une proposition injuste et amoral
permettez moi de vous dire que je ne
comprends pas comment le ministre de
l'intérieur aujourd'hui a très
lourdement insisté c'est votre
partenaire c'est votre binôme c'est
votre
c'est le continuum police justice sur
cette possibilité par ailleurs dans des
grands pays démocratiques comme
l'angleterre par exemple il existe une
contractualisation ça s'appelle l'acte
parental parenting actes il y a des
gilles effectivement qui ont mis en
place une sorte aussi de cautionnement
de contrats pour des pour des
allocations facultative et je voyais
plusieurs maires aujourd'hui qu'on
témoigner sur les chaînes d'information
en continu et qui justement quand les
familles déraper ou contre les ados
laisse les adolescents déraper supprimer
des allocations supplémentaires qui
était facultative
moi je veux bien tout entendre mais
aujourd'hui comment pouvez-vous nous
dire vous pouvez vous nous dire monsieur
le ministre quelle est la cohérence
entre les déclarations du ministre de
l'intérieur et les vôtres aujourd'hui en
quoi est-ce amoral que dans notre pays
lorsque la solidarité nationale s'engage
pour certaines familles pour certaines
prestations
et bien cette solidarité nationale quand
les familles ne remplissent pas leur
contrat lorsqu'elle se désengage de
leurs enfants
pourquoi pourquoi ces familles là
devrait être devrait continuer c'est pas
une suppression de ce mini c'est un
cautionnement
donc je fasse chacun est libre de
défendre ses positions
mais accuser la récente la
représentation nationale et certains
parlementaires parce que je sais que
nous sommes nombreux à soutenir cette
position d'être amoral ça me semble
totalement déplacé parce que ce qui est
amoral monsieur le ministre c'est aussi
de ne pas prendre ses responsabilités
quand on est parent on est responsable
de ces
enfants également lorsqu'on ne remplit
pas ses obligations
lorsqu'on ne remplit pas ses obligations
et bien un moment donné il faut aussi
que la société larry colère vous avez à
dire qu'on a passé ensemble mais ça veut
dire quand vous dépassez l'autre étant
merci monsieur sûr vous avez demandé la
parole pour une explication de vote la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues ça fait de très
nombreuses années peut-être 20 ans ou 30
ans qu'on nous parle de cette
suppression des allocations familiales
est toujours nous avons eu pour notre
part cette position de refuser cela
parce que les allocations familiales
c'est le droit de l'enfant c'est le
droit de la solidarité
et il ya toujours les gens qui nous
disent oui mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire avec l'argent des allocations
familiales
nous connaissons par coeur ce discours
mais monsieur le ministre a eu raison de
dire qu'il s'agit souvent de familles en
grande difficulté
et lorsque l'on croit en faisant une
telle pression que l'on va régler les
problèmes on ne les règle pas et c'est
constant et c'est pourquoi nous
soutiendrons fortement la position de
monsieur le ministre dans cette affaire
madame v rien à demander la parole pour
une explication de vote
merci madame la présidente l'implication
des parents c'est évident doit être
forte et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je
n'ai pas compris
monsieur le ministre il ya pourquoi
lorsqu'on a parlé de la remise aux
parents vous étiez contre puisque c'est
un premier pas justement où il peut y
avoir dialogue entre le juge et des
parents pour évoquer cette
responsabilisation et je pense qu'elle
est importante
l'idée de jouer sur les allocations
familiales pourquoi pas il me semble que
ça doit être dans ces cas là avec un
véritable accompagnement de la famille
qui l'a n'est pas du tout signalé
dans l'amendement c'est pourquoi je ne
voterai pas cet amendement parce qu'il
me semble que il y à un véritable besoin
d'accompagnement des parents et de prise
en charge de la famille avant d'aller
d'aller est supprimé très bien merci
monsieur le ministre vous souhaitez
répond monsieur brisson a demandé la
retrait d'iran parce que madame la
sénatrice vous vous avez déjà hier tenté
de créer entre l'intérieur et la justice
une sorte de fossé dont je dis
d'ailleurs qu'il est artificielle je
sais les propos qu'a tenu le ministre de
l'intérieur
il a effectivement parlé parfois d'une
responsabilité au sens où une éducation
carencé peut hélas amener vers la
délinquance des mineurs
et ça n'a strictement rien à voir avec
une sanction d'ordre pécuniaire qui
viendrait frapper des familles qui sont
déjà
déjà handicapé c'est la première
remarque la deuxième madame n'inventait
pas des mots qui ne sont pas sortis de
ma vie je n'ai pas parler de morale je
ne suis pas un moralisateur
vous avez votre moral j'ai la mienne
j'ai parlé de justice s'est
singulièrement différent enfin sur la
remise à parents la remarque que j'ai pu
faire hier
vous l'avez entendu c'est que envisager
la remise à parents comme sanction c'est
un peu désarçonnant surtout quand les
parents sont présents parce qu'il ya
aussi des parents qui connaît sa
délinquance de leurs enfants et qui sont
des parents très très présent voilà ce
que j'ai dit je sais évidemment pendre
pas contre la remise à parents il
n'entend pas opposer les enfants
délinquants et et leurs parents surtout
surtout quand ils sont bien élevés voilà
ce que je voulais dire je trouve ça je
le redis profondément injuste
socialement injuste et l'exemple que
j'ai donné tout à leur mérite est
peut-être une réponse différente et pas
polémique
vous montez sur vos grands chevaux dit
mais comment s'adresse-t-il à la
représentation nationale en l'occurrence
avec son coeur cette dame dont j'ai le
souvenir précis c'est une femme honnête
qui élève bien ses enfants deux sont sur
la bonne route
le troisième nom doit-on l'handicaper
voilà la question qui est posée
non mais pardon madame la sénatrice
c'est ça la question qu'il a posée
lawrence et des conjectures solution a
demandé la parole pour une explication
de vote
merci madame président tout à l'heure je
la demande et aussi pour défendre un
amendement demandant boyer qui n'étaient
pas là je vous invite à regarder un peu
la montagne de temps en temps parce que
j'avais demandé la parole sur les
amendements qui ont été pris brillamment
défendu par monsieur blair en l'absence
d'un envoyé moi je ne comprends pas
monsieur vers des sources c'est vous
qu'êtes augmenté sans chevaux vous avez
créé un mouvement d'indignation pour un
contrat proposé entre la justice et les
parents
une sorte de prise de responsabilité joe
danger lui après vous avoir vu indigne
et j'ai relu deux fois l'amendement pour
me demander puisque je n'avais co signer
si je n'ai pas commis quelque chose
contre le bon sens
vous pouvez parler la justice vous avez
parlé d'injustice et vous dites et vous
accusez pas d'envoyer comme cela de
vouloir
qu'est ce que le débat mais c'est vous
qui venez de lectrices paix avec bien
sûr une partie de la gauche qui dès que
l'on touche à ces questions de
responsabilité des parents excusez mon
des responsabilités des parents ça me
semble quelque chose qui appartient au
pacte républicain
je suis jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
profondément un professeur et bien moi
j'estime en effet que la justice peut
demander aux parents d'être responsable
par rapport aux mineurs est envisagé un
contrat on est en train de s'offusquer
d'un cri ya les 10 nations pour un
simple contrat demandé par j10 permettez
moi monsieur faire des sauts de pathé
d'accord avec vous et je vous ferai
alors sans intérêt l'amendement nouvel
employé merci chers collègues juste vous
dire que tout à l'heure nous sommes
trois nouveaux avoir vu vous manifestez
pour prendre la parole non mais désolé
mais nous étions
nous n'avons pas vu nous serons plus
attentifs chers collègues c'est promis
vers la montagne même apourceau poly
vous avez demandé la parole évidemment
et dmc ans sans aucune surprise que nous
n'allons pas voter votre amendement
parce que à une problématique sociale
vous répondez une fois de plus par une
approche répressive
non madame mais laissez-moi cause et
vous reprendrez la parole après vous en
avez tout le loisir vous le faites
depuis tout à l'heure pour demander des
sanctions des sanctions des sanctions à
l'encontre des familles alors nous ne
sommes pas étonnés de votre position
évidemment et toute évidence la pression
financière exercée à l'encontre des
familles déjà vulnérables dans la
plupart des cas ne ferait qu'accentuer
évidemment les difficultés mais ça a été
dit par monsieur le ministre
économique sociale et familiale et je
suis moi même allé visiter comme
plusieurs parlementaires je suis allé
monsieur le ministre à la prison de
longuenesse hui enfant de 13 ans sont à
la prison de longuenesse donc avec des
adultes ou prison d'adultes au premier
étage et je me suis renseigné sur ces
enfants qui sont ils ces enfants ils
sont des enfants de la zone pour la
plupart qui ont été baladés de famille
en famille dans des difficultés énormes
madame ils sont des enfants qui auraient
dû avoir un suivi psychologique parce
qu'ils sont souvent atteints
psychologiquement les parents madame
comme vous le dites les parents qui
aujourd'hui sont aussi à la limite mis à
l'index ses parents ils ont fait les
cmpp pour avoir des rendez vous ils ont
demandé des suivi psychologique avec des
psychologues
ils n'en n'ont pas eu parce qu'il n'y en
a pas madame voilà ce qui s'est passé
les parents les parents de ces enfants
plusieurs m'ont dit puisque je les ai
vus aussi plusieurs m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient fait les hôpitaux pour demander
de l'aide
et qu'à un moment donné il avait y
compris prévu prévenu que ses enfants
elle est passée à l'acte
et qu'est ce qui a été fait pour ses
enfants eh bien rien n'a été fait et
aujourd'hui il se retrouve à 13 ans à la
prison de longuenesse avec des adultes
dans une situation où le retour en
arrière n'est même pas presque possible
il faut se le dire
il mériterait d'être dans des structures
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ne sont pas des
criminels ils sont malades ils sont
malades voilà ce qu'ils sont ses enfants
et les parents madame qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont peuvent ses parents d'avoir des
enfants qui sont malades
voilà ce que la société aqua la société
ne répond pas et c'est pour ça qu'il
nous faut des moyens
merci chers collègues je vais donc
mettre aux voix cet amendement numéro 55
rectifié bis avec un avis favorable de
la commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui votent pour
18 qui votent contre
il n'est pas adopté nous passons à
l'article 7 avec deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'article amendement 66 rectifiée
présentée par madame benbassa merci
madame la présidente l'article l 413
tirer 1 du code de la justice pénale des
mineurs est une disposition qui prévoit
que mineurs âgés de 10 à 13 ans puissent
être tenus à la disposition d'un
officier de police judiciaire pour une
durée allant jusqu'à 12 heures
il s'agit d'une mesure de privation de
liberté pour ces enfants qui peuvent
ainsi être interrogé par la police ou la
gendarmerie sous la contrainte
cet amendement vise ainsi à supprimer
l'ensemble de la section relative à
cette procédure et elle ne devrait pas
concerner des enfants et adolescents
bien sûr moins de 13 ans nous rappelons
d'abord que juridiquement la présomption
d'irresponsabilité s'applique à ses
enfants
nous insistons ensuite sur le fait qu'à
7h ils ne sont pas en mesure de
comprendre une telle procédure ainsi que
ses enjeux
ceci n'est pas acceptable ni
juridiquement ni moralement c'est
pourquoi nous demandons la suppression
de cet article
merci merci chers collègues la maman 35
rectifiée présentée par monsieur ce
faire il merci madame la présidente
l'article 413 ciré un fixe les
conditions dans lesquelles peut être
prononcée la retenue d'un mineur comme
cela vient d'être dit par madame
benbassa l'amendement que nous proposons
limite ce dispositif aux enfants de plus
de 13 ans alors que l'article l 413 ciré
1 prévoit que la retenue pourrait être
renoncer à l'encontre de mineurs âgés de
10 à 13 ans ça nous paraît vraiment
judicieux d'être au dessus de 13 ans
mais non pas en dessous merci chaque
collègue madame le rapporteur je ne m'en
donnez votre avis sur les deux
amendements s'il vous plaît oui madame
la présidente c'est donc deux avis
défavorables
en effet nous paraît pas utile de
supprimer la retenue qui peut être
nécessaire pour avoir des informations
concernant des jeunes qui ont commis des
infractions graves des zones de 13 de 10
à présent par don d'autant que cette
relique est très encadrée parce qu'elle
est possible que si le mineur est
soupçonné d'avoir commis un crime ou un
délit puni d'au moins cinq ans
d'emprisonnement
c'est sa durée est limitée au temps
strictement nécessaire et ne veut pas
dépasser 12 heures renouvelable une fois
avec des garanties supplémentaires donc
c'est un avis défavorable
de même pour l'amendement 36 rectifié 35
défavorable monsieur le ministre mais ma
vie pour le oui c'est absolument est
parfaitement encadré un gamin de 11 ans
peut-être retenu quelques instants ne
fût ce que pour obtenir le nom de ses
complices et on a besoin de cette
procédure qui est une fois encore
extrêmement attentive aux droits des
enfants très bien donc défavorable sur
le 66 défavorable sur le 35 rectifié
parfait jamais donc on voit ces deux là
maintenant numéro 66 rectifier avec deux
avis défavorables qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre 6 7 5
il n'est donc pas adoptée
l'amendement 35 rectifier avec deux avis
défavorables qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre
ça se tient il n'est donc pas deux
amendements identiques qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 16 et le 30
6 l'amendement numéro 16 a même
clairement oui merci à madame la
présidente monsieur le garde des sceaux
peut-être pour raccourcir effectivement
au débat puisque le débat vient d'avoir
lieu et et cela s'inscrit en tout cas
dans la même logique puisque à travers
cet amendement nous cela vise
effectivement abroger le régime de
retenue pour les enfants de 10 à 13 ans
puisque ces mesures de privation de
liberté sont à nos yeux en tout cas
l'équivalent d'une garde à vue pour
mineurs et même si il y à peut-être
parfois besoin de maintenir un enfant
nous pensons que cela aurait pu être
fait notamment avec les services de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse ou
la protection de l'enfance pour
justement éviter cette situation
douloureuse d'abord pour des enfants et
qui vise finalement à renforcer une fois
encore le caractère répressif plus qu
éducatif merci cher collègue monsieur
shore oui madame la présidente même
explication que celle que vient de faire
madame pipi hermann dans le droit fil
des deux amendements précédent a fait
merci cher collègue madame leur apporta
même avis que les précédents puisque ces
mêmes causes les mêmes effets donc
défavorable
monsieur le ministre était parfaitement
dit par madame la reporter même cause
même effet mais là ma position est bien
défavorable
jamais donc on voit ces deux amendements
seraient 36 ha avec deux avis
défavorables qui votent pour qu'ils
votent pour
voilà merci qui votent contre qui
s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptées nous
avons à présent deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune le
numéro 43 numéro 44 monsieur soir pour
le numéro 43 oui cet amendement est
important pour nous madame la présidente
monsieur le garde des sceaux
mes chers collègues notre amendement
vise à supprimer la procédure en
audience unique devant le tribunal pour
enfants la procédure devant le tribunal
pour enfants en audience unique prévu
dans cet article ne permet en effet pas
le temps de travail éducatif qui est
pourtant nécessaire est déterminant pour
le jeune le texte prévoit de reproduire
la comparution immédiate des majeurs ex
flagrant délit
cette procédure ne ne semble pas adapté
pour des mineurs voire dangereuse
monsieur le ministre il y à une
contradiction entre l'esprit l'état
d'esprit que vous affichez dans l'objet
de la présente loi propre de lille
présent projet toi et cette procédure là
qui est vraiment calq et je le redis sur
la comparution immédiate des majeures
cette audience unis participent à la
gare accélération forte de la procédure
pénale prévue dans le présent projet or
il convient de rappeler que les enfants
sont des êtres en construction qui ont
besoin de temps pour grandir évoluer
mûrir
la sanction est immédiate n'est pas une
réponse efficace contre la délinquance
des mineurs
mais la rapidité de l'intervention
éducative l'est certainement
en outre le texte initial prévoit qu'il
suffit d'un rapport de moins d'un an
pour pouvoir se prononcer délai
totalement justifiée pour un mineur au
comportement par nature extrêmement
évolutif de plus nous souhaitons alerter
sur le petit
b du deuxième alinéa de cet article qui
vise particulièrement les mineurs non
accompagnés
c'est un sujet difficile nous le savons
il est en effet courant que les mineurs
en situation de migration refuse de se
soumettre aux opérations de prélèvement
souvent car ils ne sont pas informés
cette mesure interroge plus largement
dans un contexte où on constate que les
mineurs non accompagnés sont plus
souvent déférés devant le juge des
enfants
à l'issue d'une garde à vue est
davantage incarcéré que le reste des
mineurs délinquants
le rapport 2018 de la contrôleur général
des lieux de privation de liberté fait
état d'un tiers de mineurs non
accompagnés dans certains quartiers
mineurs et jusqu'à 50% en établissement
pénitentiaire unique
la généralisation des audiences unique
sera donc né fasse pour les mineurs en
général et pour ces mineurs non
accompagnés en particulier merci
monsieur sphère la maman numéro 44
vous avez madame arriver merci madame la
présidente
c'est un amendement de repli par rapport
à celui de le précédent dans l'hypothèse
où on maintient la procédure d'audience
ioniques
pour nous il convient de hausser le
niveau d'exigence pour qu'il y soit
recouru c'est à dire de plus l'encadrer
sinon c'est ce qu'on avait souligné
depuis le début des débats et dans notre
discussion générale
sinon il deviendra rapidement la voie de
droit commun et signera la disparition
de la spécificité de la de la justice
des mineurs
donc on propose d'encadrer et on
rappelle quand même que une simple
décision parce que c'est un tracé le
problème des réitérant c'est vrai que
vous allez nous répondre que ça ne
concerne que les réitérant mais on pense
qu'une simple décision antérieure de
culpabilité ne peut pas suffire à
justifier le recours à la procédure
unique et qu' il faut l'encadrer pour
pas que ça devienne la procédure de
droit commun on voit bien l'intérêt
c'est on est un peu à la limite c'est un
peu un exercice d'équilibré on le
reconnaît mais on aime on préférerait
l'encadrer de manière à éviter que ça
devienne la procédure de droit commun
merci madame la merci cher collègue
madame la rapporteure vos avis sur 43 et
merci dans la main présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
sommes favorables à l'audience unique on
a eu l'occasion de le dire lors de la
discussion générale et nous pensons que
ça fait partie de l' équilibre de ce
texte de permettre notamment pour
certaines situations vous l'avez évoqué
madame la sénatrice les réitérant on
sait que c'est souvent en 5 % des jeunes
qui sont dans une spirale souvent
infernale qui occupe 50 % des affaires
et pour ces jeunes là ont qui sont
connus que du très connu des services de
la police très connu des services des
magistrats très connu de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse et pour eux il
faut une réponse rapide avec une
sanction rapide c'est l'utilité de cette
audience unique qui ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y aura pas de mesures éducatives
que ces mesures éducatives
elles interviendront soit en amont soit
en aval comme
toujours c'est prévu donc nous sommes
favorables à un maintien de l'audience
unique qui répond aussi vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur le sénateur sur avis de
réponse à certaines situations un peu
particulière qui sont celles des mineurs
non accompagnés
mais faut pas réduire l'audience unique
aux mineurs non-accompagnés ans non
accompagnés pardon mais c'est une
réalité de la situation certains jeunes
et pour ces jeunes gens qui tombent dans
la délinquance c'est vrai que cette
audience unique y répond tout en sachant
que elle doit rester une exception et en
aucun cas devenir le principe ça c'est
certain mais nous émettrons des avis
défavorables sur aux deux amendements
monsieur le maire je pense madame la
présidente que tout a été dit d'abord
l'audience unique
nous y sommes nous l'avons déjà dit j'ai
eu l'occasion de m'exprimer sur ce sujet
précis extrêmement attachés ça fait
partie de du change de 7 de cette
procédure
et puis ça n'interdit en rien les
mesures éducatives ça vient d'être
rappelée l'instant je mets donc deux
avis défavorables rien je mise donc
convoi l'amendement 43 avec deux avis
défavorables qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté un amendement de repli numéro 44
avec deux avis défavorables qui votent
madame arrivé pour explication oui on va
maintenir cet amendement parce que
quelque part c'est cette audience unique
c'est pas le principe de l'audience
unique c'est vraiment les moyens qui
sont derrière pour faire en sorte
qu'elle soit elle ne devienne pas la
procédure de droit commun c'est petit
c'est ça notre souci il faut que vous le
compreniez et avec le problème des des
petits réitérant et le problème d
dmn a aussi donc c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on proposait d'encadrer par contre là
on prend un pari on fait un pari parce
que c'est un des éléments importants de
la réforme ont fait un pari
moi je demande à voir quand même par
rapport aux problèmes qui se posent et
aux moyens qui sont derrière et je
voudrais bien faire le pari que ça
devienne pas la procédure de droit
commun mais on a un doute important
c'est pour ça qu'on maintient cet
amendement pour prendre date sur sur ce
paris là et nous allons mettre aux voix
chers collègues donc qu'ils votent avec
deux avis défavorables qui votent pour
cet amendement numéro 44 qui votent
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté deux amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune là l'amendement
40 et 17 la maman numéro 40 précieux ce
faire oui madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre collègues il s'agit
d'introduire un peu de souplesse dans le
travail des magistrats
au vu des situations merci cher collègue
madame kuperman pour l'amendement numéro
oui je vous remercie madame la
présidente monsieur le garde des sceaux
je la revends la dérive sur cette
question des aides dont nous avons parlé
déjà hier et bien évidemment nous
entendons la volonté du gouvernement de
procéder à une exploration de la justice
et une mise en culpabilité prendre c'est
essentiel d'ailleurs pour fluidifier le
travail des juges pour les accusés mais
surtout pour les victimes qui n'entame
bien souvent leur travail de
reconstruction qu'après le verdict cela
ne doit cependant pas se faire au
détriment des droits fondamentaux et y
compris ceux de la défense la question
des délais donc centrale et l'idée même
d'ailleurs d'une fourchette de della
unique pose question tant les mineurs ne
disent pas tous du même accompagnement
les professionnels que nous avons pu
rencontrer nous ont d'ailleurs alerté
sur un point précis le délai de trois
mois est largement insuffisant parfois
inadaptés à des jeunes sans suivi
éducatif je parle bien de cela c'est
pourquoi nous proposons pour ces mineurs
de permettre un allongement de ce délai
jusqu'à six mois merci cher collègue
madame le rapporteur vous avis sur ces
amendements
oui merci madame la présidente alors le
premier amendement le numéro 40 qui
supprime le des maximales de 3
avant l'audience de culpabilité donc il
revient sur les délais or on sait que
les délais c'est aussi le coeur de la
réforme ce qui va faire l'efficacité de
ce nouveau code de justice pénale des
mineurs
c'est de pouvoir juger le jeune dans un
temps réduit 10 jours à trois mois pour
la culpabilité et à partir de ce moment
là se mettra en place les mesures
éducatives et pourra se mettre en place
aussi la sanction est tout travail
autour de la personnalité du mineur doc
ça me parait sera pardon un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement
quant au deuxième amendement de numéro
17 de la crique herman avec moi je
comprends pas tout à fait la logique
parce que je trouve que au contraire
pour les jeunes qui n'ont pas de suivi
convient que l'audience de culpabilité
soit rapidement prononcée pour que se
mette en place les mesures prises en
cohérence donc voila ce mot si un avis
défavorable rien merci monsieur ministre
deux fois défavorable madame la peau du
parfait
je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement numéro 40 avec deux avis
défavorables qui vote pour qui votre
compte qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement numéro 17 avec deux
avis défavorables qui votent pour compte
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
avons maintenant deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
mehr 73 et 78 73 présenté par le
gouvernement
monsieur ministre au tueur cet
amendement la présidente pour des
raisons de cohérence
l'amendement numéro 78 présenté par
madame le rapporteur rédactionnelle
nanos président monsieur le ministre
votre avis sur sept amendements
rédactionnels
défavorable je mets donc on voit cet
avis
c'est un mandant pardon avec un avis
donc favorable de la commission
puisqu'il est introduit par le
rapporteur est défavorable du
gouvernement qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui s'abstient il est donc
deux amendements qui font également
l'objet d'une discussion commune 39
rectifier le 18 39 rectifié madame
arriver merci madame la présidente
ce ça concerne les articles l 433-4 réel
433,5 qui fixe les conditions dans
lesquelles la détention provisoire du
mineur de moins de 16 ans peut être
prolongé nous proposons dans notre âme
en manque une révision automatique de la
détention provisoire et lieu tous les
tous les trois mois
là je veux dire si presque de la
cohérence avec la logique de la réforme
puisque on veut éviter la détention
donc quand on est en détention c'est que
quelque part il ya un dysfonctionnement
et donc mettre un délai de trois mois ou
une obligation de révision dans les
trois mois
c'est une manière aussi d'accélérer le
processus merci merci chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la garde des
sceaux c'est quasiment en tout point à
le même amendement il vient donc d'être
défendus mais nous pensons effectivement
qu'il y a besoin de plus de régularité
et d'encadrement sur cette problématique
de l'enterrement
la garde des sceaux est un monsieur le
garde des sceaux
il se fait tard aussi madame le
rapporteur votre avis madame la
présidente monsieur du quart des sceaux
alors sur l'amendement 39 sur le
réexamen tous les trois mois de la
détention provisoire nous on pense que
la main levée possible à tout moment en
matière de détention provisoire
elle peut même être inférieure à 3 mois
d'autant qu'il ya un problème aussi
d'affectation dans votre amendement
puisqu'ils concernent à la fois c'est le
l 433-4 les mineurs de moins de 16 ans
et le l 433 5 cd mineur de 16 ans et
plus donc voila nous émettons un avis
défavorable quant à celui de madame que
kerman qu'en faire uniquement les crimes
des mineurs de moins de 16 ans et sommes
aussi défavorable très bien merci
monsieur le garde des sceaux et la
présidente le délai prévu par le texte
ces six mois mais nous savons que
l'assistance de l'avocat d'une
obligation évidemment et que là au cap
et à tout moment
présentée toute demande de mise en
liberté qu'il estimerait devoir
présenter nous sommes défavorables à ces
deux amendements qui aurait pour
notamment pour conséquence d'alourdir
considérablement la la la la la charge
de travail
du magistrat l'avocat peut faire la
demande à tout moment et j'imagine le
pardon juge des enfants les sens qu'on
pire un gamin en détention sans prêter
plus attention que cela sa situation
merci monsieur le ministre je mets donc
aux voix l'amendement numéro de 39
rectifier avec deux avis défavorables
qui vote pour qui votre contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté un
amendement numéro 18 avec deux
amendements des deux avis pardon
défavorable qui vote pour qui votre
compte si ça tient
il n'est pas vous adoptez je mets aux
voix l'article 7 qui est pour contre
ascension
l'article 7 est adopté
[Musique]